syndicats et collectifs hospitalier
entend donc on l'aura compris maintenir
la pression sur l'exécutif dans la
dernière ligne droite du ségur de la
santé pour en parler nous sommes avec
nathalie et comptines et economy
spécialiste de la santé bonsoir d'intel
nicotine et merci d'être avec nous à vos
côtés pour cette partie décryptage
stéphane guye et infirmières bloc
opératoire chu de béziers secrétaire
général du collectif inter bloc bonsoir
à vous aussi merci d'être avec nous
alors déjà petite question
voilà qui vous concerne et aussi avant
d'évoquer ce ségur de la santé cette
journée de mobilisation on imagine que
vous avez écouté en tout cas d'une
oreille l'audition d'agnès busin avec la
question des masses qui vous a beaucoup
touché 1 stéphanie juillet dans les
hôpitaux donc en clair la ministre
n'était pas responsable de cette gestion
des stocks de masques elle était
uniquement responsable des commandes
l'état fait tout son possible et
n'aurait pas pu mieux gérer en tout cas
en termes d'anticipation
vous avez été convaincu par votre ex
ministre de la santé
non tu lu ment pas c'est les faits sont
là on a bien vu sur le terrain nous
qu'on n'avait pas de masques notamment
des masques ffp2 qui sont les seuls je
tiens à le préciser à protéger contre le
coc vie même si certaines
recommandations parlent simplement n'est
pas ce que c'est une jcct au faut savoir
que nous au bloc par rapport à la grosse
mobilisation du virus on est en première
ligne
donc forcément le sp2 est le seul qui
nous protège et le sp2 est celui qui
manque cruellement et même encore à ce
jour dans tous les blocs
nous ça a été comme partout en france et
d'ailleurs ça a été la solidarité
nationale et citoyenne qui a fait que
nous avons eu des masques ffp2 bien
souvent ils étaient périmés mais bon
c'était mal points mais on va dire on
s'est protégé avec ce qu'on a ce qu'on a
eu à disposition
nathalie continer sont commentées dans
les détails votre impression sur
l'audition d'agnès buzyn c'est ça a
l'air d'être un petit peu comme les
réponses toutes faites bon sont les
masques elle devait pas les commandes et
par devait commander mais c'est pas elle
qui est à l'origine de la commande en
parle
je pense que de cette commission
denquête ne sortira pas grand chose
effectivement et que franchement le
gouvernement en tout cas au début de la
crise
c'est un peu pris les pieds dans le
tapis c'est tellement compliqué alors on
va pas c'est donc à cette mobilisation à
quelques jours de la fin du ségur de la
santé stéphanie billet vous êtes
satisfait de cette journée de
mobilisation ça fait des mois des mois
et des mois que vous vous rassemblez il
ya eu les dernières annonces du ministre
qui datent d'ailleurs d'hier
vous espérez encore que ça puisse porter
ses fruits
on espère on espère toujours de toute
façon si un se mobilisant les uns et
stora le rapport de forces qu'on y
arrivera sans doute à quelque chose mais
non on n'est pas satisfait de tes
répondre ce que nous apporte jusqu'à
maintenant puisqu'on parle d'une
enveloppe de 6 milliards d'euros pour
les personnels non médicaux donc l'état
elle charme et les as lémanique radio 6
milliards d'euros il faut savoir que ça
répond pas du tout à la l'augmentation
que l'on espère qu'il serait de 300
euros net par mois par agent ça ne même
sept français en euros ne rattrape pas
encore la place désastreuse de corona de
la moyenne nationale de la moyenne
européenne des salaires des infirmiers
donc sinon on n'est pas satisfait bien
sûr que non après au niveau mobilisation
nous on voit bien que la mobilisation
est forte que les soignants sont excédés
écoeuré enragé donc je pense que de
toute façon on ne lâchera rien c'est pas
possible c'est pas possible on ne peut
pas avoir fait tout ça pour arrêter
maintenant donc on a continué 60 session
nathalie comptines et pourtant ce qu'on
se trompe quand on lit que ces 6
milliards d'euros c'est sans aucune
commune mesure avec ce qui a pu être mis
sur la table lors des précédents en plan
en faveur du secteur
serait ce donc il faut bien mon avis
rendre compte c'est que ça fait plus
d'un an que les soignants on est le
collective intelligence collective un
terme aux pitots donc ça fait plus d'un
an que les soignants sont mobilisés
partout en france pour défendre
l'hôpital public
la réponse du gouvernement pour le
moment en a absolument pas été à la
hauteur des attentes était besoin de cet
hôpital public même si ce gouvernement
n'est pas responsable de l'état de
délabrement pendant lequel
progressivement les différents
gouvernements ont mis le pied tall
public
il est face à une crise qui a montré à
l'ensemble de la population que les
revendications de ces personnels étaient
pour le moins légitime
on a tous vu des photos de deux
soignants avec des blues fait sacs
poubelles ou des masques donner
généreusement par la population autour
donc l'hôpital public et sous et
sous-équipés sous financé ces personnels
sont mal payés il ya des femmes
d'organisation qui sont importants la
dimension administrative est beaucoup
trop fort qu'il faut revoir la
gouvernance il faut revoir
l'organisation du système de soins dans
son ensemble lien avec les personnes
nées des médecins libéraux pour la
permanence des soins l'ennemi avec les
cliniques privées
donc il ya beaucoup de difficultés
autour de cet hôpital public et pour le
moment
la réponse du gouvernement est très très
en dessous des besoins de l'hôpital
public et bien sûr des attentes des
soignants qui vivent ça tous les jours
au quotidien alors quotidiennement les
soignants trouve confrontée à ces
difficultés alors stéphanie est une
question aussi de répartition similaire
c'est beaucoup d'argent on l'a dit mais
on apprend aussi que cette enveloppe va
aller vers les ehpad et cliniques
privées ce qui n'était pas
nécessairement prévu dans les
négociations disons que il faut bien
s'asseoir partager avec tout le monde
puisque c'est tous les soignants en
globalité qui demandent une augmentation
est pas peu les hôpitaux il ya aussi
effectué ma les ehpad ya les cliniques
privées
on est tous logés à la même enseigne le
souci qui est assez commun cette
enveloppe va encore être redistribuées
est-ce qu'elle va être redistribué à la
mode prix meukow vide comme ça a été le
cas certaines scènes sans certains 1500
d'autres mille d'autres aurier c'est
tout ça qui est inquiétant c'est on se
doute bien que ça va pas du tout
satisfaire ce que ce que l'on attend et
ça va certainement pas sauver le peu de
service public qui nous reste et moi
j'ai beaucoup beaucoup d'inquiétude par
rapport à la suite de la gestion de
cette crise parce que la crise est passé
pour le moment on sait très bien que
dans certaines régions il ya des cas de
convives de nouveaux qui reviennent en
force
si on doit subir une deuxième vague et
bien je ne sais pas comment on va la
gérer
et puis c'est pas à re distribuant comme
ils comptent le faire ou on verra demain
ce que vannes c'est monsieur bien mais
je crains beaucoup encore que ce soit a
fait un peu de manière arbitraire et
c'est tout à fait même une âme ici alors
nathalie côté des autres courroux de la
part des personnels médicaux cette fois
une enveloppe de 300 millions d'euros à
destination
les quelques cent mille 1 personnels
médicaux ça a été annoncé hier par le
ministre c'est très insuffisant on
imagine pour ses médecins bien sûr mais
ce qu'il faut bien comprendre c'est que
ces histoires de salaire que ce soit les
soignants ou les personnels médicaux
outre les personnels qui sont autour de
l'hôpital
c'est pas seulement une juste
rémunération pour pour ses personnels
bien sûr que son écurie
mais c'est au delà de ce à dire que les
rémunérations sont tellement faibles
dans l'hôpital tunique comparer soir à
la difficulté vis en région parisienne
par exemple sous aux salaires comparés
au privé par exemple que les hôpitaux
publics n'arrivent pas à recruter dans
l'hôpital public notamment en
ile-de-france ya des centaines et des
centaines de postes qui sont disponibles
mais qui ne sont pas pour nous donc
annoncé des créations de poste n'a pas
de sens si ses créations de postes ne ne
trouve pas preneur
donc la question des rémunérations elle
est double elle est à la fois pour les
personnels que ce soit les médecins ou
les soignants la bleue problématique et
même parce que ça c'est une rémunération
qu'il mérite en tout cas pour les
soignants et en ont besoin et ça a été
rappelé les salaires aujourd'hui des
infirmiers sont très bas dans l'échelle
de des rémunérations européenne des deux
personnes est l'équivalent donc ça c'est
pas normal mais c'est aussi parce que si
ces salaires ne sont pas revalorisés on
ne trouvera pas de personnel dans les
hôpitaux publics et qu'effectivement là
on peut s'inquiéter très fortement de
que ceux qui de ce qui va se passer pour
ces hôpitaux publics alors comme ça a
été dit s'il ya une deuxième vague mais
tout simplement si on a besoin nous
l'ensemble de la population d'aller se
faire soigner parce que sans personnel
c'est son délit qui ferment ce sont
aussi des malades qu'il faut pas
accompagné donc on n'a pas le temps de
s'occuper d'eux et on sait que des soins
proprement dits mais y'a pleins ceux
autour du soin qui sont nécessaires pour
que ces patients puissent puis se guérir
et supporter leur séjour à l'hôpital
donc c'est la survie aussi
l'hôpital public qui est en jeu dans ces
questions financières et de salaires les
annonces d'olivier verrons demain merci
à toutes les deux nathalie comptines et
stéphanie lui est d'avoir été avec nous
en direct sur rt france après cette
nouvelle journée de mobilisation des
soignants